***
*Schüsse eines Maschinegewehres*
*Stöhnen*
Ich krieche durch einen Luftschacht
für Science vs. Fiction, als ob.
*knackende, knarzende Geräusche*
Du scharrst zu viel,
stirb langsam, Jack.
Zu viel gibt es nicht, Henry.
"Stirb langsam" ist mein absoluter
Lieblings-Weihnachtsfilm.
Hast du diesen Sprung
vom Hochhaus gesehen?
John McClane ist einfach krass.
Jack, John McClane
kann springen wie er will,
aber die Physik bescheißt er nicht.
Wollen wir wetten?
Wette angenommen.
Wie hart ist John McClane,
das checken wir jetzt.
Welcome to the party...
*Chor-Gesang:
"Freude schöner Götterfunken"*
♪ Freude, schöner Götterfunken,
Tochter aus Elyseum.
♪ Wir betreten feuertrunken,
Himmlische, dein Heiligtum.
Tag zusammen, Jack ist hier.
Wenn Bruce Willis
auf Terroristen trifft,
dann ist nicht nur Weihnachten
angesagt, sondern auch viel Action.
Und weil "Stirb Langsam"
in einem Hochhaus spielt,
geht es dabei auch immer irgendwann
definitiv richtig tief nach unten.
*Schuss*
Ob und wie John McClane
seine Sprünge überleben kann,
dass klären wir heute.
Und zwar gemeinsam
mit unserem Terror-Physiker Henry.
*knackende, knarzende Geräusche*
Hi Jack!
Ich habe es mir
schon mal richtig bequem gemacht.
Aber ich kann dir jetzt schon sagen,
für John McClane
wird es heute richtig unbequem.
Quatsch, das ist ein harter Kerl.
Der kann so was ab.
Aber bevor es sich Henry zu
gemütlich macht in seinem Sessel,
schauen wir uns die Sprungszenen
mal an.
Mit dem netten Menschen von kino.de.
Marek hat sich die mal angeschaut,
2 hat er rausgesucht.
Hier kommt Nr. 1.
Hallo Jack!
In "Stirb langsam" teilt John
McClane nicht nur ordentlich aus,
er muss auch viel einstecken.
Manchmal muss er sogar wegrennen, um
nicht selbst erschossen zu werden.
So wie in dieser Szene.
Hier flieht John McClane
vor 2 Terroristen.
Doch seine Flucht
endet in einer Sackgasse.
Der einzige Ausweg
ist ein Luftschacht,
den er natürlich nimmt.
Er versucht sich am Riemen
seiner Maschinenpistole
durch den Schacht abzuseilen.
Was, wie man sich denken kann,
nicht funktioniert.
Der Riemen reißt und John McClane
rauscht den Schacht herunter.
Im letzten Moment sieht er den
Eingang in einen anderen Luftschacht
und hält sich daran fest.
Sodass er die ganze Aktion übersteht
ohne dass ihm irgendwas passiert.
Habe ich doch gesagt, krasser Typ.
Einfach ordentlich festkrallen
und sich dann wieder um die Rettung
der Geiseln kümmern.
Als Geisel würde ich danach
nicht mehr mit John rechnen.
Lass uns das mal in dieser Szene
Schritt für Schritt durchgehen.
Hier hängt er noch am Seil
der Maschinenpistole.
Dann reißt das Ganze
und er fällt für ca. 2,5 Sekunden.
Durch die Fallbeschleunigung
auf der Erde
würde er auf 24 m/s beschleunigen.
Das sind 88 km/h.
Er versucht zwar hier in der Szene,
sich noch mal abzufangen,
aber das würde ihm rein physikalisch
auch nichts helfen.
Am Ende ist er so schnell
wie ein Auto auf der Landstraße.
Na und, das ist doch wohl
kein Problem für John McClane.
Also wir haben in unseren Folgen
schon über Fälle gesprochen,
wo Menschen aus mehreren
1.000 m Höhe gefallen sind
und trotzdem überlebt haben.
Dann schafft John diese Szene
ja wohl locker.
Jack, du vergisst dabei was.
Die Leute, die aus so großen Höhen
gefallen sind,
die sind irgendwie
gepolstert aufgekommen.
Außerdem haben die nicht versucht,
ihr ganzes Körpergewicht
mit den Händen abzufangen.
Ich zeige euch mal, wie viel Kraft
dabei auf Johns Finger wirken.
Die Kraft gibt es in unserer
Lieblingsformel: F=mxa.
Kraft ist Masse mal Beschleunigung.
Ich habe mal gegoogelt.
John McClane, also Bruce Willis,
der wiegt 83 kg.
Dann braucht man noch
eine Beschleunigung.
Eigentlich ist es ein Abbremsen, man
nennt es trotzdem Beschleunigung.
Hier ergibt sich
Delta v durch Delta t,
also Geschwindigkeitsänderung
pro Zeit.
Die Zeit, die er braucht,
um sich mit den Fingern
im Schacht abzubremsen,
sind nicht mehr als 0,2 Sekunden.
Dabei bremst er sich von den 24 m/s
aus dem freien Fall auf Null ab.
Wenn wir das in die Formel
einsetzen,
ergibt sich eine Kraft
von ca. 10.000 Newton.
Das ist echt enorm.
Das entspricht dem Gewicht eines
Kleinwagens nur auf den Fingern.
Okay, gut.
Dann braucht er hier vielleicht
ein kleines Weihnachtswunder,
damit er das überlebt.
Is christmas, dear.
It ist time of miracles.
Weihnachten hin oder her.
Wenn seine Finger
das aushalten würden,
dann müsste er auch das Auto
mit den Fingern anheben können.
Das ist Quatsch.
Viel Wahrscheinlicher ist es ja,
dass es ihm dabei
entweder die Arme ausreißt oder er
lässt los und fällt in den Schacht.
Und da braucht es schon mehr als ein
Wunder, dass er das überlebt.
Also eher Zauberei.
This is a joke.
Do have any ideas serious that is.
Sorry, der musste sein.
Rest and peace, Alan Rickman.
Auch wenn ich mir
meinen Weihnachtshelden
ungern kaputt reden lasse,
in dieser Szene sieht es echt
schlecht aus für John McClane.
Aber der Film heißt nicht umsonst
im Original "Die Hard",
also Dickschädel oder zäher Kämpfer.
Lasst uns mal schauen,
wie zäh John in der 2. Szene ist.
In dieser Szene befindet sich John
McClane auf dem Dach des Hochhauses,
das mit Sprengstoff versetzt ist.
Das macht er natürlich
nicht zum Spaß.
Nein, er will die Geiseln
herunter holen.
Die zögern aber, denn sie sehen
einen Polizeihubschrauber,
der zur Rettung naht.
John McClane schießt ein paar Mal
in die Luft.
Daraufhin rennen die Geiseln
panisch nach unten.
Blöd nur,
dass jetzt die Polizei John MacClain
auch für einen Terroristen hält.
Ihm bleibt nicht viel Zeit.
Kurzerhand schnappt er sich
einen Feuerwehrschlauch,
bindet ihn sich um die Taille
und springt vom Hochhaus.
Gerade noch rechtzeitig,
bevor alles in die Luft geht.
John wird nicht nur
von den Terroristen bedroht,
auch noch von der Polizei.
Whole shit.
Kann ich nicht versprechen.
War mir klar.
Lass uns auch noch mal diese Szene
Stück für Stück durchgehen.
Hier steht er noch oben
auf der Brüstung.
Dann springt er idealerweise
in dem Moment los,
wo gerade der Sprengstoff
gezündet wird.
Dann fällt er 17 s lang.
Dann wird er von diesem
Feuerwehrschlauch aufgefangen.
Ja, aber Jack,
die Zeit ist super unrealistisch.
Wenn du dir die Szene
noch mal genau anguckst,
dann siehst du, dass der in 9 s
gerade mal 1 m weit gefallen ist.
Das kann ich nicht akzeptieren.
Und warum?
Die haben ja hart gecuttet, damit
der Fall dramatischer aussieht.
Aber wir können jetzt mal grob
abschätzen,
wie tief er wirklich gefallen ist.
Als Referenz
nehmen wir den Feuerwehrschlauch.
Die sind bis zu 30 m lang.
wenn wir das vergleichen
mit der Zahl der Stockwerke,
die er gefallen ist, kommt das
mit den 30 m schon ganz gut hin.
Siehst du, Henry, genau der Schlauch
rettet ihm am Ende auch das Leben.
Da hat er richtig Glück gehabt.
Der hätte auch statt dieser 30 m
die komplette Gebäudehöhe
runterfallen können.
Das wäre 150 m gewesen.
Ja.
Prinzipiell stimmt das.
Die Geschwindigkeit, mit der man
beim freien Fall unten aufschlägt,
ergibt sich aus Wurzel aus 2 mal
Erdbeschleunigung mal Fallhöhe.
Für die 150 m des ganzen Gebäudes
würden sich 200 Sachen ergeben.
Bei den 30 m des Feuerwehrschlauches
ergibt sich nur der Wert: 87 km/h.
Yippie ya-yeah, motherfucker.
Weniger Geschwindigkeit, d.h, es
wirkt auch weniger Kraft auf John.
Die Schlauch-Idee war total clever.
- Nein, war es nicht.
Weil, der Schlauch
ist kein Bungee-Seil.
John McClane wird nicht langsam
abgebremst sondern ruckartig.
D.h., es wirkt eine super hohe Kraft
auf die Stelle,
wo er den Schlauch umgebunden hat.
Ich habe das mal
mit der Formel ausgerechnet,
die wir vorhin beim Schacht
benutzt haben.
Das ergibt eine Kraft
von 9.000 Newton.
Oh fuck, schon wieder
der Kleinwagen.
Der zerrt in dem Moment an Johns
Taille, wo der Schlauch ihn abfängt.
Das ist heftig.
Yippie ya-yeah, motherfucker.
Ich kann euch das sogar
veranschaulichen.
Der Science-YouTuber Jake Roper
hat das mal mit einem
Ballistic-Dummy nachgestellt.
Da sieht man, in dem Moment,
wo der Schlauch den stoppt,
reißt es den komplett auseinander.
Und der hat den nur
aus 10 m fallen lassen.
Also nicht mal die Hälfte des
Wertes, den wir jetzt benutzt haben.
Also Jack, das überlebt auch ein
John MacClane nicht.
Okay, Schweinebacke.
Du hast gewonnen.
Also halten wir fest:
Ja, John McClane
bräuchte schon mehr als ein Leben,
um heil
aus dem Gebäude rauszukommen.
Trotzdem bleibt das mein
Lieblings-Weihnachtsfilm.
Das lass ich mir nicht kaputtmachen.
Vielen Dank an Marek von kino.de,
der uns die Szenen erklärt hat.
Auch ein Danke an Henry
fürs Erklären.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt jetzt
ein paar schöne Weihnachtsfeiertage.
Schaut auch ein paar gute Filme.
Wenn ihr keine Folge mehr
von uns verpassen wollt,
macht uns ein Geschenk und ...
... drückt den Abo-Button ...
und ... die Glocke.
Dann können wir uns schon
nächste Woche wiedersehen.
Zu einem Silvester-Special.
Ich würde mich freuen.
♪ Hier sind noch Videos,
die ich ziemlich feiere.
♪ Im ersten
geht es um Michael Myers.
♪ Aber auch Kevin,
den checken wir aus.
Also klick da drauf,
klickt da drauf, klickt da drauf.
Frohe Weihnachten!
Copyright UT MDR 2022